die operation die die ärzte an der johns
hopkins universität in baltimore in den
usa durchgeführt haben hat weltweit
schlagzeilen gemacht
in einer 14 stündigen operation haben
die mediziner erstmals einen penis
mitsamt hodensack transplantiert
empfänger war ein us soldat der in
afghanistan verletzt worden war
der penis und der hodensack stammen von
einem verstorbenen spendern den eingriff
führte ein team aus neun chirurgen und
zwei urologen bereits am 26 märz aus der
schwierigste teil der operation war
dabei zahlreiche arterien und venen
miteinander zu verbinden
die transportation sollte dem jungen
soldaten helfen wieder ein normales
leben zu führen sagt der direktor für
plastische chirurgie in der johns
hopkins universität dr
wir glauben dass es bisher ein erfolg
ist allerdings war die operation erst
ende märz ist also noch sehr früh wir
erwarten dass der patient das
krankenhaus in dieser woche verlassen
kann
eine wiederkehr der fanzonen kann aber
dauern das gilt sowohl für das urinieren
als auch für die sexual funktion nerven
wachsen sehr langsam deshalb kann es
viele monate dauern bis einige
funktionen zurückkehren
summers function komiker der operierte
soldat gab eine kurze schriftliche
erklärung ab als er aufgewacht sei habe
er sich endlich wieder normal gefühlt
das sei typisch sagt dr
viele verletzte veteranen haben gesagt
dass sie sich nicht mehr ganz fühlen
wenn sich ihre genitalien teilweise oder
ganz verloren haben deshalb ist das
etwas was ihnen hilft sich wieder ganz
zu fühlen
körperlich aber auch psychisch wir
denken dass es hilft ihre identität ihre
männlichkeit und ihr selbstbewusstsein
wiederherzustellen
das wurde deutlich als wir mit diesen
patienten gesprochen haben aber auch bei
gesprächen mit anderen männern
es handelte sich nicht um die erste
penis transportation weltweit aber um
die erste verpflanzung eines penis
mitsamt roden sack die erste
erfolgreiche penis verpflanzung war 2015
in südafrika
tag gemeldet worden